[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation your host down sake on got an
interesting thoughts on episode for you
today we're gonna be talking about
McGregor vs. Eve now this is a little
bit strange because what just happened
was a very important fight for the
Ultimate Fighting Championship for UFC
who is UFC 229 and a lot of people are
fans of UFC and UFC is in many ways
important because it's like you know men
and women figure out how to really
challenge their bodies to the PICUs
performances out of all humans that
you're the strongest you're the best
mixed martial artist that you have the
best art and strategy of fighting of
close quarter combat without weaponry
besides just your body and that's really
fascinating and cool but and it's been
done for a long time now ever since
we've really evolved from chimps we've
been figuring out how to do close
quarter combat now but it's been with us
since we've evolved basically but
something that is also very strange
about this process is kind of the just
the simple fact that we're still bashing
each other in the face the fact that
we're actually fighting so the point of
you know seeing if we can choke the
other person to death or if we can give
them concussions and knees to the face
or whatever it may be organ injuries
sometimes people die in these fights
that we're kind of it can be a little
bit like haven't we why haven't we
transcended fighting yet so there's kind
of this dichotomy between UFC which is
you know peak performance of human
bodily achievement and then the other
one is sort of like are we gonna
transcend fighting so that's this
interesting dichotomy that I've been
posed with but there's also another
really important aspect of this to talk
about which is that
the fights themselves are very lucrative
so there is pay-per-view and the
fighters make a lot of money and my
question earlier when we when we
actually saw the Logan Paul ksi fight
that happened the boxing fight that
happened was that is it possible that
they're making money from the fight and
then they're choosing to invested in two
cool things like charities and and
solving world problems and starting
companies and acting on entrepreneurship
and hiring people to do all of that
because if that was the case then that
would offset a huge amount of the you
know critique around this type of stuff
so that's the same question for McGregor
and a beep is is it possible that they
are taking the money and funneling it
into really important endeavors for
progressing humanity or is it just more
watches and jewelry and cars and boats
and houses and stuff like that because
when does the conspicuous consumption
end
really when does the materialism end
really so and we when we had this
conversation a couple months ago
adjourned Peterson it was super clear
like you get more meaning in your life
when you go and solve world problems
than when you buy a third boat or a
third house or a third car or whatever
it is you can take that money and start
an entrepreneurial project that can
bring a lot of meaning and value to
society
so the fight was also especially
important because there were actually
really harsh words spoken between the
fighters beforehand and this is becoming
more and more tribal in many ways that
this is anti you know anti-russian or
anti-muslim or anti whatever it may be
and that that is not good that we are
tribally fighting like that this earth
is one tribe and we are lucky and
grateful to have this place together and
the fact that we're still calling each
other out across the nation borders as
horrible people without even knowing who
someone is
is it's extremely bad and difficult to
deal with and find reparations through
so that was apparently one of the
reasons why khabib after the fight was
really angry and went out and tried to
dropkick Dennis and he ended up there
Dillon Dillon and he tried to dropkick
him and and that's that was that that
was a major issue of the fight as well
as afterward there was a whole mob of
fighters versus a mob of fighters and
amongst the two teams that were fighting
against each other
blindsiding each other all this kind of
stuff and that looks kind of bad for the
UFC and that the question is now like
what are we gonna do moving forward how
are we gonna have very calm but also you
know very still fighting but calmer
fighting and what are the athletes doing
with their money why can't we just be
more transparent about all these things
and how can we transcend fighting and
transcend ego in general so we can
figure out how to sustain and progress
collectively so these are just some of
the thoughts on the McGregor could be
fight on UFC 229 you know something that
I found really interesting about what
we're doing right now is that you know
all we're talking about UFC right now
and the last couple thoughts on episodes
were on attention and time it was on the
me to movements and Cavanagh and then
there was another one that was on we
just did it on sociopathy and Jake Paul
so we're talking about sociopaths we're
talking about me too we're talking about
time and attention and social media and
the technology economies and that kind
of stuff in our time about so this is a
multidisciplinary show that's the point
of what I'm saying and if you stick
around us and join this community we
will continue talking about the
disciplines and how they all interact
and engage with one another and how that
gives us a better more well-rounded
understanding of the world that we live
in and how we can best move forward
thanks everyone for tuning in you know
sparring is actually quite fun really it
is and I and I do spar and I would you
know sparring is something that's just
good it feels
good you know for your body to move
around like that but at the same time
you never want to purposely want to hurt
someone only if you are absolutely being
challenged about to be physically
injured do you want to use that and so
when we do this whole thing on the fight
stage it's it becomes a whole different
nuanced conversation thanks for tuning
in to this episode we greatly appreciate
it
go and create go build go manifest your
destiny much love and we will see you
soon
peace
[Music]
you